last chance to enjoy the Sun then it's
back to UK it's gonna be cold it's gonna
be horrible good morning
last day in LA I can't believe these
days just blew by so fast it's crazy I
have a lot of stuff that I need to get
done today this is the last day I have
to make sure I sign all those I got a
record two videos and then there's a
party tonight and your brothers are
coming along 1600
the 1601 if you want one of these
posters make sure you check out Peter
Pienaar come there's clearly a limited
supply all right video one house
compress and wagon all right video my
voice is like dead after that I'm just
gotta edit it now yay they're fun stuff
see if I boys this day they are finished
edited yes
thumbnails [ __ ] isn't that the best
damn option well if it isn't the best
thumbnail this town is ever new people
still see like a ten minute video and
they're like ten minute video that
showed he just ten minutes I can do that
when editing and uploading and
thumbnailing and all this stupid [ __ ]
takes forever I have never been able to
do more than five a day that that kills
me for a day I'm like [ __ ] yes five a
day I'm dead three a day that's what I
aim for two a days what I up
the food price secret is out so now I'm
done with all this stuff I needed to do
before I had to go it's time to pack I
finish packing
I have so much more stuff than I what I
brought I hope it will fit last chance
to enjoy the Sun then it's back to UK
it's gonna be cold it's gonna be
horrible
it is unbearably hot in here but it's
still really not oh my god more packages
seriously we're leaving tomorrow because
I'm going to be on The Colbert show my
family is actually flying in just to
meet me and support me they're really
nice so please stop sending packages to
this address because I'm not going to be
here anymore
and they're probably just gonna be
pissed at me if they keep getting
packages so thank you for everyone who
sent it it's very nice but now you can
stop
a pedophile art nice what is this yes
thank ya this is [ __ ] awesome oh oh
yes this is amazing I'm going inside for
this one this is a big moment because do
you know what's in this more time no
it's my book for the person I've never
seen at a real copy of I just seen like
document obviously so the publisher
penguin send with it
hmm okay is it wrapped no oh okay here
we go
what the hell is this why guys I want
the book not nuts I think you got it
wrong what is this that's real funny
guys I thought I was gonna get the book
oh my I we have today yeah and one
giving this to us third time hahaha it's
awesome that oh god oh god what is it
doing here get it up
yeah that's disgusting I like it
okay guys you rise up yeah who came up
with this idea who thought this was a
good idea
no yeah Dada Dada Dada Dada
turtle.turtle
George Oh duh yes this book loves you
it's the first time I hold it in my hand
oh I feel so good a touch oh this book
is cleverer and better-looking than you
this book will blow your mind
let's put gloves you oh my god this is
so cool
your pet only loves you because you give
it food life without nipples would be
pointless there's some jokes that are
just too dark that I we were just like
alright we'll both say that duck made
the Joe
and then that's where how we get a rid
of it you may not be strong you may not
be good enough you may never even be a
decent person I forgot the rest so the
book is filled with a [ __ ] ton of courts
like these that I wrote and I had a
blast writing it and I just can't wait
for you bros to have this in your hand
I'm so excited I'm watching Ken fail at
legend of the brofist we got it we got
the save point I'm watching through the
book and this is the only page I drew
myself
it feels bittersweet to leave I am
looking forward to go back home meet the
pugs get back to old routines but at the
same time it's just so nice here but I
will come back next month and it'll be
great I know a lot of you are curious
what's gonna happen with the vlog I
might take a little break like a couple
days break but then I'm actually gonna
start traveling again next month it's
crazy this month are insane I bet you
all think I'm like super lazy not doing
anything but these two months of gorge
are very very different I feel very
fortunate for all the amazing stuff
that's happening like the game is turned
out great I have a good feeling about
the book too and this thing that we've
been filming is was I like I don't care
how it goes it was just so fun to film
if it's half as fun to watch than it is
to film then it's gonna be a hit and
just looking back how I started off I
would never have imagined to be doing
any of this
and it's just so cool I'm just so happy
and grateful my ride is late
is waiting
fun times
oh my god it's Tyler Oakley okay I'm
here with Jeff Jeff and Jamie and people
apparently I'm not allowed to go there
because they will freak out
the big announcement the big
announcement is coming guys Jeff are you
excited he's excited he's so excited
okay I am back home why am I talking
like an [ __ ]
it's 11:49 I'm going up in four hours
and I'm already so tired I feel really
bad about myself for myself today was a
big day you don't know what happened but
it was huge and once you see it you will
have sympathies okay I'm gonna go
another quality day on this shoot oh my
god it smells so much
what's gonna happen
I'm from the world gonna end this part
it's like when you divide by zero